hi I'm Evan Carmichael and welcome to
the major case for $10,000 contest as
entrepreneurs if not every day that we
get the opportunity to get valuable
business tools and resources for free so
I'm really excited about this contest I
partnered up with sage simply counting
linkedin and staples and we're looking
for a toronto-area entrepreneur to give
over ten thousand dollars in prizes too
entering for your chance to win is
really easy just visit simply 10k calm
and tell us how you can use safe simply
counting linkedin and staples to help
grow your business we also want to learn
a little bit more about you your story
and the challenges that you've overcome
to get to where you are today then tell
your friends to vote for you and
increase your chances of you being able
to win
three finalists will be chosen for an
event in toronto on May eleventh you'll
have ten minutes to present your case
for why you deserve the window $10,000
and prizes in front of a panel of three
judges and I'm going to be one of those
judges I'm also going to profile the
entrepreneur who wins give them some
extra exposure on my website and answer
some of their top business questions to
learn more and to enter into the contest
check out simply 10k calm and hopefully
I'll see with the finals in May good
luck